فكان من الضروري ايجاد مساحات خاصه بهم
مطاعم ومنتجات غذائيه نباتيه بالكامل وحتى
تطبيقات المواعده انشات للنباتيين
والبيئيين
لدينا الكثير من قصص النجاح شهدنا عددا من
الزيجات كما اصبح لدينا اطفال جريزر كما
نسميهم ليس في المملكه المتحده فقط وانما
في انحاء مختلفه من العالم فالمنصه ليست
للمواعده فقط وانما لمساعده الناس على
ايجاد اصدقاء
الحب والصداقات لا يزال الكثير من الناس
يرفضون مواعده النباتيين ويعتبرونهم
مستفزين
[موسيقى]
ما هي مش حلوه هذه الاسلوب هذا منه حلو بس
انه كل واحد عنده رايه الشخصي وكل واحد شو
بيرتاح بياكل بس انه اجباري لا ما بعتقد
انا بوافق على الراي والله الراي الصحيح
يعني الانسان حسب طبيعته طبيعه الانسان هو
في ناس نباتيين يعني من طبيعتهم وفي ناس
لا يحبون ياكلون كل شيء في الحياه يعني
فشي مو اجباري يعني هذا اختياري للناس